elles sont jeunes
[Musique]
mais la plupart de ces femmes sont déjà
rompues au combat leur unité entièrement
composée de femmes appartient à la
branche armée du Parti de la liberté du
Kurdistan le pack un parti d'opposition
au régime iranien cure des iraniennes
c'est plutôt en Irak qu'elle s'entraîne
ah c'est aussi ici qu'elles ont combattu
le groupe état islamique au sein des
forces de la coalition internationale
parmi les combattantes un visage qu'on
ne peut vous montrer pour protéger sa
famille elle n'a que 19 ans et se
familiarise avec son arme il y a à peine
quelques semaines elle manifestait dans
les rues d'Iran à sanenda il y a vu
impuissante des amis tués par les forces
de répression du régime iranien
il est frappé avec des bâtons et les
blessés dit-elle même une fois blessé il
continuait de frapper alors on ne
pouvait pas les atteindre pour empêcher
les gardes révolutionnaires de les
emporter on ne pouvait pas appeler
d'ambulance pour les blesser il serait
allé directement en prison ou dans les
locaux des services de renseignement
pour être torturés
le même sort que ses parents ont
contacté le pack avec l'aide d'un réseau
clandestin de passeur et la traversée
les montagnes rudes et inhospitalières
qui sépare l'Iran il ira pour rejoindre
les combattantes
m'ont dit de partir rejoindre les forces
armées Kurdes raconte ma Frisk que je
serai en sécurité c'est vrai que je suis
en sécurité ici j'apprends tout ils
m'ont donné une arme et m'ont enseigné à
tuer mon ennemi
avec la mort en détention de Massa à
mini ici Massa est connue sous son
prénom kurde Gina prénom qui n'est pas
reconnu par la République islamique
d'Iran qui n'enregistre officiellement
que les prénoms de langue perse
veut aujourd'hui que la peur change de
camp plus jamais elle ne sera sans
défense dit-elle
contre les régimes iranienne dit-elle et
je veux leur faire ce qui nous font des
attaquer les tuer pour qu'ils sachent ce
que ça fait
le même parcours périlleux depuis la
région en majorité kure de diront
jusqu'ici et non ça écrit
ils ont arraché mes cheveux
racontrezannes j'ai vu mes amis autour
de moi être blessés l'Iran prétend que
nous sommes tous égaux dans la société
ce sont de grands menteurs l'Iran et la
pire dictature que vous ayez jamais vu
mais pas tant qu'elle ne pourra pas
faire face au gouvernement à armes
égales pour chacune de leurs balles
dit-elle il faut répondre avec une balle
les innocents qui manifestent ne peuvent
pas se défendre sauf avec des pierres
soit il se défendent avec des pierres
soit il fuit le régime d'Iran au-delà
d'un sentiment de liberté et de
puissance ce que les jeunes femmes
retrouvent ici c'est un sentiment
d'appartenance appartenant à une culture
et à une histoire
ils sont environ 10 millions les Kurdes
d'Iran représentent le troisième groupe
ethnique en importance au pays
historiquement la province du Kurdistan
irakien le rochalat en kurde a toujours
tenu tête au régime islamique de Téhéran
ces habitants subissent des
discriminations importantes depuis bien
avant la Révolution islamique et la
répression il y a toujours été plus
sévère
dès le début des manifestations en Iran
le 16 septembre dernier sanendage la
capitale du Kurdistan iranien en est
devenu l’épicentre le Kurdistan Human
Right Watch une organisation basée à
Paris a pu confirmer la mort de 54
Kurdes aux mains des forces du régime
iranien depuis le début du soulèvement
populaire
pendant des années nous avons été
réprimés dit-elle par le régime iranien
on ne peut pas parler ou étudier dans
notre langue maternelle à l'école
avant de trouver refuge auprès d'elle
résonne ignorait presque tout dépêche
mergats du bac et de l'histoire de son
peuple
très patriotique dit-elle mais ici j'ai
appris que j'ai une terre un pays qui
est occupé par une ennemi on ne nous
permet pas les mots cures de la bas ils
veulent éliminer notre identité
une identité qu'elle revendique
aujourd'hui et qu'elle veut défendre par
la force irakien
[Musique]